for those of us who change mobile
handsets frequently a large part of the
junk lying around in drawers is likely
made up of a vast array of different
mobile charges no solamente lost our
address cambian con las marcas de avilés
sino que dentro de una misma marca
tambien los cargadores tambien div oh
sorry often no se aburre pizanno is so
absurd Matt no es que no es logico
searching for a phone charger that works
with your phone will soon be a thing of
the past as the European Commission
promoted an agreement with 13 leading
mobile companies to offer a standard
charger based on a micro USB connector
the first such charges are expected to
be introduced on the EU market in early
2011 in ostraca city so no viene de aqui
Garriga battery peroni the European
Commission asked manufacturers to
harmonize charges in the EU in a bid to
make citizens lives easier and cut down
on waste la commission ROP adobo molt a
la mente lady savuti de parte de seated
in econ intervento forte anche depart a
parliamentary up AO adichie saudi the
resolver el problema del there are
multiple Ishita they carry gab at
elizaveta phony the new universal
charger will be compatible with mobile
phones that can connect to a computer
but it's expected that this kind of
mobile phone will be predominant in the
EU market in a couple of years we went
to London to meet Peter Harrison who on
behalf of Nokia was satisfied with the
brand new electronic equipment instead
of having lots of charges we just go to
one solution from early 2011 EU
consumers will be able to purchase new
mobile phones with compatible charges
but will it be possible to buy a mobile
phone without the charger in principle
we could sell sales packages without
without the charger but it really
depends on the market dynamics and the
customer need and we have to monitor
that and see how that goes annick the
european consumer watchdog welcomes the
move to standardize battery charges easy
gain of time Guinness face listen home
rental costs and it consists on the need
to monitor the implementation of this
bond
agreement is a solution thanks to the
new stand-up so one thing we will have
to be careful about us and the Member
States doing market civilians that no
brand implies that you have to use their
own specific charger with their own
specific phone at the moment there are
more than 30 different types of charger
for phones across Europe environmental
experts death an oddity said common
sense had prevailed and pointed out this
deal will also encourage more charges to
be recycled you can see the huge bulk of
W Tripoli waste behind me and you can
realize that this is only a very small
amount but we need to start with
something and I think this is a very
good initiative the migration from the
current company specific standards to a
common standard will be gradual la vida
davonte noi gambia in poem a lograr SI
una sistema muroga Brady Kerrigan
battery SI funciona request o sistema
credo che sarà inevitable a a la guerre
questa pacifica revolution Anka tutorial
tree y sistema take on